Transcriber: ÖZGE İŞBECER
Gözden geçirme: Ömer Faruk Zeren
Siz hiçbir su kaynağının bittiğini,
çiçeklerin, ağaçların, hayvanların
sonunun geldiğini gördünüz mü ?
Dünyada karşılaştığımız sorunlar
bizi niye bu kadar korkutuyor?
Kendi sonumuzu getirdiğimiz, yaşadığımız
dünyaya verdiğimiz zarar yani kendi
davranışlarımızın sonucunu görmek
bizi niye bu kadar şaşırtıyor?
Sürdürülebilirlik, dünya üzerinde yaşayan
insanların gelecek nesillere de
aktarabilmeleri için kaynaklarını
tüketmeden kullanmaları ile ilgilidir.
Tuğlalardan örülmüş beton yığınları ve
duvarlardan ibaret binalar arasında
kalmaya o kadar alışmışız ki, bu sınırlar
dışında olup biteni görünce normal dışı
bir şeymiş gibi davranıyoruz.
Ama aslında sınırlı ve çok değerli olan
vaktinizi küçük adımlar bile olsa
değerlendirmemiz gerekiyor.
Evet, şu anda yaşadığımız dünya belirli
bir düzen içinde olabilir ve bu düzenin
değişmesi için zorlu ve uzun
bir yol da olabilir.
Ama değişimin istendiği zaman ne kadar
kolay olabileceğini gösteren Japonya,
2021 yılında eko kasabalar projesini
hayata geçirerek çevreci ve otonom
şehirleri hayata getirdi.
Eğer onlar yapabiliyorsa
biz neden yapamayalım?
Geçtiğimiz Haziran ayında bir sosyal
sorumluluk projesi için Tekirdağ'ın Saray
ilçesinde bulunan Sihirli Tohumlar
Permakültür Çiftliği'nde üç gün kalarak
doğal yaşam deneyimleme şansımız oldu.
Aylin Ertem ve Süleyman Ertem’in amaçları
çeşitliliği ve sürdürülebilirliği gözeten
bütünün bir parçası olabilen
ve tüm canlılarla anlamlı ilişkiler kuran
bir yaşam biçimi geliştirebilmek.
Bu çiftliğe, bu çiftliğe çiftlik demek
aslında bunu basitleştirir.
Çünkü bu 32 dönümlük arazide yer alan
biyoçeşitlilik sayesinde her şey büyük
bir ahenk içinde devam etmekte ve üretilen
ve tüketilen her şey doğal bir
şekilde tüketiliyor.
Şimdi biraz kendi deneyimimden
bahsetmek istiyorum.
İlk olarak orada görebileceğiniz üzere
kulübede kahvaltımızı ettik.
Ve tabii ki de her şey doğal bir
şekilde burada üretilmişti.
Burada Aylin Hanım bizlere belirli
kurallardan bahsetti.
İlk kural da deodorant ve parfüm gibi ozon
tabakasına zarar verebilecek kimyasal
içeren ürünleri kullanmamız
kesinlikle yasaktı .
İkinci kural ise böcek ilaçları
kullanmamız kesinlikle yasaktı .
Çünkü dediğim gibi bu çiftlik bir düzen
içinde devam etmekte ve bu düzene gelen
en küçük zarar bile tüm sistemi
bozabilir bir durumda.
İlk günümüzde Aylin Hanım bizlere
bostanları gezdirdi ve bitkilerin
bakımlarına yardımcı olduk.
İkinci gününde ise medikal bir bitki olan
sarı kantaron bitkisini topladık ve cam
kavanozlarda ki zeytin yağlarının içine
özlerini bırakmaları için bıraktık.
Üçüncü günde ise sıcak kompost...
Şu fotoğrafta görebileceğiniz üzere nasıl
çalıştığını öğrendik ve
sıcaklığını ölçtükten sonra ters çevirdik.
Çünkü sıcak kompost ters
çevrilmesi gerekiyordu.
Burada öğrendiğim deneyimlerin sadece
burada kalmayacağını ve hayatımın her
yerini etkileyeceğine eminim.
Buradan da sizlerin elinde Sihirli
tohumlar, Sihirli Tohumlar ailesine bir
kez daha bizi ağırladıkları ve bizimle
yaptıkları bu değerli paylaşımları için
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Sürekli değişen ve dönüşen, devam eden
dünyamızda bizler de tamam mı devam mı
sorusuna devam diyerek hep birlikte daha
iyi bir gelecek için çalışalım ve
elimizden geleni yapalım.
Teşekkür ederim.